a
[Música]
agosto 2013
tengo la idea de contar sobre la muerte
de dos amigos míos una campaña
publicitaria
estoy petrificado de miedo dando vueltas
en la cocina de casa mis papás
me encuentro a mi mamá
no me dice que te pasa
le platico el proyecto
una semana después el proyecto se titula
ni uno más
y todo eso surgió por una clase que
tenía que se llamaba estrategia
publicitaria en donde la gran empresa de
nike invitaba a mercadólogos aún estando
en la carrera a diseñar una campaña
publicitaria que invita a la corredores
dentro de 18 y 25 años
lo primero que se me vino a la mente fue
tengo que contar la historia de mahou y
de miguel porque no sé si se acuerde en
el 2013 2013 en méxico el segundo lugar
de muertes en jóvenes eran los
accidentes viales no conocíamos las
plataformas de uber la mentalidad del
mexicano joven era de padrotes que estás
manejando pero el chingón eres y esa
historia no la pueden contar mis amigos
se quedan en el camino
mediáticamente esa campaña agarra una
fuerza que yo creo que ninguno de mis
amigos estando en la carrera lo
imaginamos televisa azteca polvo grandes
marcas deportivas se unieron a la causa
y ganamos en primer lugar a nivel
nacional hicimos que cinco mil jóvenes
en el 2013 cuando la vida fitness no
existía se paraban un domingo y corrían
en el zócalo
en ese momento dice rodrigo
está pasando es algo primer momento
profesional que estando en la carrera
me detuve y dice ok estoy logrando esto
puede haber estos dos factores que tenía
en mi vida uno había sido el miedo el
miedo ese que me había congelado en la
cocina mis papás y dos el tiempo siempre
yo era mañana es que cuando conozca esa
persona le doy la propuesta no cuando ya
haya tomado el diplomado eso no
después lo checamos me di cuenta que el
mañana no existe lo único que tenemos es
aurich
y sabía nada más que tenía el miedo de
la hora y decidí dice rodrigo a partir
de hoy vas a subir en tu tractor de
miedo
y va a seguir
comparada
sin parar aunque lleves porque te quedas
de dar cuenta que allí donde donde nace
tu mayor miedo está al lado de tu mayor
esto
después de esto que se hizo toda una
campaña mediática grupo carso en
específico américa móvil traían un
concepto de venir al 'times' que traigan
a méxico de periodismo digital querían
innovar con un grupo de jóvenes
reporteros vídeo reporteros contar
historias y me contactan y me dicen
rodrigo
creemos que tu storytelling no los
cuentas en investigación periodística y
yo
no había buscado salir en la carrera que
no iba a ser que iba a ser periodismo y
radio
el director general visitamos a pagar
esto de todo en la carrera yo ya me
llama mi señor reportes
y empecé empecé en el periodismo y me
metieron a prostíbulos abuso de menores
corrupción todo dónde está la tragedia
ya fuera en estar en este país que se va
ahí estaba yo documentándolo y me la
compré y seguía trabajando con ese miedo
día a día me llegaban amenazas de muerte
hasta que en el mundo de la producción
para los que compartan conmigo este
bello mundo el 'derecho de piso' se gana
y no importaba si yo era amigo de quien
fuera el 'derecho de piso' no lo tiene
que haber ganado y me dicen sabes que
estás listo para producir más orale lo
que vengas a hacer me pongo a producir y
lo mío ese es el estilo de vida turismo
la vida me manda a que una de mis
producciones termine en la secretaría de
turismo en el consejo de promoción
turística de méxico como antes bien
conocido visitmexico
y ahí les dicen saben que queremos que
él produzca las piezas para el grupo
dinosaurios que llevaban ahí trabajando
fue como que tengo ya lleva seis meses
de presentar
y fue como de elx y mejor ni hay tanto
boy & bass
pero cuando dije ok otra vez
el tractor dice vámonos lo tomé y no
estuve 12 93 años produciendo para
visitmexico bueno sí
gran territorio del país tuve un
acercamiento único a la cultura la
gastronomía las tradiciones a grandes
personajes que hoy en día tesoro ha sido
las experiencias más bonitas de mi vida
viviendo de eso
ganamos los derechos olímpicos para
transmitir los juegos olímpicos para
américa latina y me dicen vas y hacer
estilo de vida brasil y pues todo mundo
iría cómodo que vas a obtener migra
brasil puede ser el miedo de que no
teníamos el know-how no teníamos cómo no
sabíamos cómo se hacían juegos olímpicos
nosotros llevaban estos dinosaurios
mediáticos haciendo lo que son método
mediante mismo monstruos espejos y ya
llevaban mucho tiempo hasta que televisa
siendo los olímpicos y estamos marcando
la historia de las telecomunicaciones en
méxico
me voy y dentro de mis propuestas locas
rodrigo propuso pues meterse a una
favela agradar a la familia donde pues
está pasando todo el casting y es de las
zonas rojas de inseguridad en el país de
brasil y cuando yo con mi cámara y con
el guía turística me temblaban las
piernas
y dije no es que no que no lo vale no lo
voy a morir por por mis ideas pues
cuando dije te subiste a este tractor si
no se va a detener tu eres así y vas a
ir hasta donde llega es me metí a la
favela hicimos una pieza muy buena a la
semana gustó mucho y fue como de vila
mimosa vila mimosa es la calle la zona
roja igual de prostitución y de trata en
brasil en río de janeiro
y ahí es un encuentro también muy duro
el ver menores de edad pero cuando digo
menores niñas viviendo esa realidad no y
pues
todas mis piezas y todo y toda mi
proyección y profesional y va en
incremento y va creciendo creciendo
hasta que desaparece el consejo
promoción turística de méxico la cuenta
que era como mi motor de inspiración
desaparece y entro en una enorme
depresión
no tengo idea quién es obligo
porque quien quiere lo peor es que ni
siquiera sepa dónde va
y es ahí cuando empiezo a replantear mi
vida
termino una relación personal esto me
mandó a la lona
cuando me doy cuenta de esto los empiezo
hacer cosas que nunca me había atrevido
a hacer empezó hasta el pelo largo lo
pinto es usar este tipo de joyería
eso como a retar mis normas y mis
límites que tenía yo puestos conmigo
mismo hasta que dije bueno a ver atrás
estás pasando de la
valls
cuáles son tus opciones vámonos a canadá
maestría te endeudas pero te vas a tu
medida llegan los problemas sabiendo yo
que pues los problemas que siguen aquí
en china donde estés no cambian
abres tu productora yo quería abrir mi
productora y poder tener yo ya la
dirección y la participación completa
entonces mi jefe el presidente del grupo
y muchos de aquí seguramente conocen es
arturo elías ayub
me tenía que sentar con arturo y
plantearle el proyecto todo empezaría
como de wait echar todos los temporales
exactamente a ver por dónde le va
esperándonos
y un día al hablar su asistente dijo oye
cuando encuentres un espacio me acomoda
ahora le va eso fue una semana yo pensé
que se iba a tardar porque pues va a
generar todo es muy ocupada y un marco
un día yo estaba grabando un accord en
el foro dice oye le acaban de cancelar
tuve una cita tiene 10 minutos
ahorita más
en mi cámara que tenía la presentación
en ese momento los del business planta y
ni siquiera estaba estructurado
dice rodrigo otra vez
con este [ __ ] tractor
porque pase lo que pase atrás esa puerta
va a ser lo mejor que está pase en tu
vida porque si existe bella del grupo te
vas a ir si es quedarte va a ser lo que
estás buscando y / y le platiqué el
proyecto
se trabajó con otros directores y con
otros dos productores y hoy en día se
llama mx ser víctimas
y es un regalo es un regalo el poder
hacer lo que me apasiona el poder
comunicar y es ahí cuando me di cuenta
que en ese trayecto de que había
desatado en la cocina de mis papás
ya en ese en ese tractor había subido
más elementos ya había subido elementos
que se llamaban la pasión el detalle la
persistencia intrínsecamente bien
se habían hecho parte de mí
hay una frase que espero
decirla bien porque me falló ahorita
pero dice más o menos así
los aprendizajes son regalos
incluso cuando el maestro es el dolor y
hoy en frente de ustedes les digo que
eso fue lo que me logró estar aquí el
dolor
y el miedo y no dolor de victimización
de pena sino de incomodidad tienen que
estar ahí donde la incomodidad los llamé
donde sea lo suficientemente incómodo
ahorita estamos una etapa como lo habían
mencionado los otros expositores de
cambio solamente les digo que somos
creadores todos tienes que saber que
quieres
para que lo quieres y el cuándo
no tienen ahorita no hay otro cuando es
ahorita por eso los invito a que la
acción que más miedo les haya
surgido en la cabeza de realizar hoy
mismo la vagina papel porque ese es el
gran talento los creadores el poder
bajar de este plano al plano material
una vez le preguntaron al hermano de
walt disney arroyo
que sentía que su hermano no pudo ver
todo lo que creó y le respondió
walt fue el primero que vio todo antes
que nosotros de lo tenía x
regresando agosto 2013
hay una frase que me marcó mucho de
ronaldinho está leyendo el fútbol que
dice más o menos así
yo nací siendo nadie y nadie será igual
que yo
cuando estoy con mi mamá terminando de
platicarles mi proyecto mi mamá se
voltea me agarra de la mano
y me dice
rodrigo
el mundo está listo para recibir
logras
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a